merci mon cher collègue l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale numéro 7 de
monsieur philippe bas monsieur musée à
l'intérieur
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
la loi du 11 février 2005 relative à
l'égalité des chances à la citoyenneté à
la participation des personnes
handicapées est d'ores et déjà devenu
une des grandes lois de la république
elle prévoit le principe de
l'accessibilité pour tous cette
accessibilité s'agissant du transport en
voiture automobile peut se faire grâce
notamment à la carte de stationnement
qui est attribué par la commission des
droits et de l'autonomie de nos maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées aux personnes affectées d'un
handicap suffisamment fort il se trouve
que nous avons naturellement dans nos
communes de nombreuses places de
stationnement pour personnes handicapées
mais il arrive aussi qu'une personne
handicapée doivent stationner en dehors
de ces places réservées aux personnes
handicapées
il peut s'agir de places libres de droit
il peut aussi s'agir de place soumise au
paiement d'une redevance
quand il s'agit de places soumise au
paiement d'une redevance qui sont
utilisés parce que elles sont plus
proches du lieu où se rend la personne
handicapée ou tout simplement parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres places
disponibles si la personne handicapée
doit acquitter la redevance elle va
devoir se déplacer
jusque à la borne la plus proche pour
pouvoir payer cette redevance et prendre
son ticket un certain nombre de communes
ont décidé d'exonérer les personnes
handicapées de cette redevance je
constate que ça n'est pas le cas partout
loin s'en faut de nombreuses personnes
handicapées se voit ainsi freiné dans le
bénéfice de ce principe d'accessibilité
généralisée c'est pourquoi monsieur le
ministre je vous demande de quelle
mesure vous comptez prendre pour
permettre la généralisation de
l'exonération de la redevance en faveur
des personnes handicapées
titulaire de la carte délivrée par la
maison départementale
chers collègues les paroles de monsieur
manuel valls à l'intérieur
je ministre monsieur le sénateur
philippe bas vous m'interrogez donc sur
la
possibilité de généraliser à tout le
territoire les exceptions de redevances
de stationnement dont bénéficient les
personnes handicapées dans certaines
villes comme vous le rappelez dans votre
question l'arrêt et le stationnement des
véhicules sur le territoire de la
commune sont des compétences du maire et
de son conseil municipal et il en va de
même pour la définition du montant des
droits de stationnement qui peuvent être
exigés bien sûr comme vous le signalez
également et vous connaissez
parfaitement ces sujets la
réglementation du stationnement payant
peut tenir compte de la différence de
situation qui existe entre les usagers
la jurisprudence a ainsi confirmé que
lorsqu une différence de situation le
justifie certains usagers peuvent
bénéficier d'un tarif préférentiel ou
être dispensé du paiement du droit de
stationnement certaines communes ont mis
en place donc des exemptions pour les
personnes handicapées et il faut saluer
ces initiatives mais cette compétence
reste strictement communal et ne
pourrait être étendue sans modification
législative
je ne peux qu'encourager tous les
communes à suivre les exemples que vous
évoquiez mais je ne peux les oeufs les y
oblige et s'il ne le souhaite pas et ce
serait vous le savez méconnaître le
principe de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales et je
connais l'attachement de cette assemblée
au strict respect de ce principe
par ailleurs je crois que ce domaine
doit rester une compétence communale
puisque c'est le maire qui connaît
évidemment le mieux les besoins exprimés
localement par l'ensemble des usagers
surtout de modification législative nous
restons ouverts
évidemment temps avec ceux qui suivent
ces questions au sein de votre assemblée
avec ma collègue marié arlette carlotti
quai en charge ce sujet ce domaine là
pour pouvoir améliorer
les choses et pour pouvoir étendre
progressivement
cette possibilité que nos concitoyens
handicapés que leurs familles attendent
bien évidemment
le ministre monsieur philippe bas
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
d'avoir rappelé que l'exonération de la
redevance pour les personnes handicapées
titulaire de la carte de stationnement
ne contrevient nullement au principe
d'égalité puisque la différence de
situation entre la personne handicapée
celle qui ne l'est pas justifie une
différence de traitement je regrette que
s'agissant du principe d'égalité nous
n'ayons pas encore pris l'initiative
de généraliser au plan national une
pratique qui se faisant dans certaines
communes et pas dans d'autres induit
entre les personnes handicapées une
certaine inégalité je suis d'ailleurs
certains que les maires de nos communes
leurs conseils municipaux ne verrait pas
d'un mauvais oeil le fait que
l'application de ce principe d'égalité à
toutes personnes handicapées vivant en
france puisse se faire dans de bonnes
conditions vous avez fait une ouverture
quant à une modification législative
je comprends que le gouvernement n'y
serait pas opposé je serai satisfait
qu'il la propose mais s'il ne la
proposent pas je suis certain que des
parlementaires ne manqueront pas de le
faire dans une prochaine occasion je
vous remercie